[Music]
anyway
yeah speaking of sucking feet this drake
cheating oh yeah
please explain this to me so at this
point it will be
i don't you know i don't know it kind of
it came and went
kind of like uh kind of like drake and
this dude's girl okay
then we came and went so they've been
together for eight years
um i guess engaged for eight years and
who
uh stood on instagram jamie's son like
that's his name and then i forget his
ex-fiance's name
hold on all right so drake flies naomi
out
to do a feature okay and be
[ __ ] okay
to put it gently
he put his penis in her vagina got it
they had sex yeah oh okay to just kind
of you know
be respectful the situation he [ __ ]
her
okay got it and so uh
didn't he fly them both out
no he i think that was part of the story
wasn't it i thought he just flew her out
and he or no yeah he did he did fly them
both out yeah and they're both really
hype and he's getting on the private jet
and they're like oh my god this is what
a crazy opportunity
and then they smash so now
the the man
drake [ __ ] somebody's girl you kind
of almost want it to happen to you
because this dude got super powers
like in the kind of way that you know
josh richards and bryce hall being
single for the summer
does it exude that sort of energy it's
it's it's not
really on that level if i'm being honest
okay i mean i don't think anything can
really touch that level of
alpha or confidence let me
that truly is white boy summer you know
josh richards and bryce hall
single just slaying
pooch
anyway look at the superpowers this dude
got from his wife
cheating on him with drake
this guy should fight jake paul man
what the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
just wait looks like what
i mean i mean pause it for a second that
that was cool but it was also just a
little bit of
parkour yeah it also was super lame at
the same time yeah i know
i mean imagine imagining this video
being like in an urban environment oh
bro
dude i'm so sad about my girl cheating
on me with drake
yeah right and he jumps across like a
building gap
you're like yeah you're sick you're
definitely sad
nah you're like crying every single
night
just stop lying to everybody
uh bro nah the best the best reply to
that is dude
uh shout out dragonfly jones with the z
if you're this good at martial arts you
got to be annoying as [ __ ]
drake probably just pours this young
lady some vino and cracked an anchorman
joke and she didn't know what hit her
like you know it's so true like
have you ever known anyone who can do
these things these
this thing yeah they're insufferable
really
yeah like certain certain kinds of
people that can do this
activity they just suck yeah like you
know who they are because in a group
setting they'll fold their arms and do a
half split
while standing and they're always kind
of just like like what we were joking
about
yeah oh yeah interesting point yeah
basically
and they're always kind of like just
like shaking their hips a little bit
like they're just kind of ready to
bust it out at any moment
yeah she came home from the drake trip
and walked in the front door and he was
just
both feet up on the wall like this arms
crossed like so babe what happened
no he's like how was the feature how'd
it go
rotates he's upside down now
how was it how was it
yeah you have a lot of fun hold on i'm
gonna switch i'm gonna switch stances
here
he's just hanging on the wall being
annoying and she's like
i [ __ ] him
he backflips what
then and he does like a [ __ ] like
one-legged like capoeira
flip like kick into the air and lands on
his knee
just what she's like she's like
i did it i [ __ ] him and he's like oh 7
20 punches the wall what i can't believe
you do this to me
is that the wall to the ceiling
[Laughter]
flip he just runs and
jumps through the window to the roof
next door
does it somersault i'm out of here no
dude
i [ __ ] him turns around runs straight
to the window just jumps out
yeah yeah comes back up through the door
she came through
in their apartment building you what i
can't believe you did this to me
[Laughter]
you got to know drake saw that so here's
the funniest part is he
released a single uh
because i think this guy is like a
singer or something as well
and the art for that was this 3d orb
and it was it was colored white and that
was a cover of a single
and drake announced his new like candle
perfume or some [ __ ]
and it's the exact same cover but it's
dark darker toned like it's the inverse
of it
it's it's like that's [ __ ] sinister
yeah yeah jet yeah the best thing i saw
was
drake is a villain he is he stabs and
twists it
that's brutal yeah and he's probably
gonna make a song about her
oh no and have her on a song and blow up
her career too
yeah make her famous and so she's rich
as [ __ ] too
yeah and then just and he's still doing
this
yeah and then drake drake what can you
tell us about naomi
oh she's a nice girl
oh she's a nice girl
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
he runs up a wall fingertip grabs the
ceiling
pulls himself close to it does like the
baby like
then pushes himself back down lands on
two feet like a cat
dude bro and what makes it what makes
him
even or like even worse looking i feel
is she posted this thing singing like
her
like response to the whole situation and
it's
it's honestly beautiful no way yeah let
me
link this before we do that what was his
caption to this tweet
oh no no this is just some dude
oh that's not actually him no no no
that's him that's okay
okay okay no but it's just like someone
ripped this i don't know where he posted
this oh reels he posted on his reels oh
what was his caption the oh i got the
beast has been
the beast has been released that was his
caption he had another really
depressing post it's him on an airplane
with a glass full of ice that says i
don't drink champagne poppy
oh no cash said my wife did
oh yeah seriously no comments allowed on
that one for good reason
yeah jesus christ so yeah so
you know so he posts like three parkour
videos
[Laughter]
that's crazy you know like you heard a
dude bad if he's doing parkour
that's something you could you could
tell how good you had someone
based on their post-breakup like workout
routine yeah they're just deadlifting
and just like lifting heavy it's like
all right that's traditional hurt that's
just like ah
lift something big get out the system
yeah lawyer up but that [ __ ]
is like i'm doing mma now yeah yeah yeah
hurt yeah hurt that's so true
let's listen to her real quick
oh my gosh it sounds like amy winehouse
or something
[Music]
[Music]
what if she started getting really
specific
[Music]
[Laughter]
my cervix bro wait
pause this first of all i don't take
away from her insanely talented yeah
someone needs to take his parkour
footage and put it over this you about
to do it you have to play that [ __ ] on
mutant
[Laughter]
oh my god bro yeah man yeah she's just
weirdly weirdly specific the
the first three lines are so uh like
astute she she was like
uh so something like after i've
confessed
i still miss you that's just like damn
oh
it's like the way she put him down just
to lay him gently
[Music]
i mean she's about to blow up after this
honestly oh yeah
how many likes does this have 382
thousand views damn
killing it
[Laughter]
no
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's all i was thinking about the
beast has been released
yeah yeah when her voice would flutter
like that i'm like man picture that
backflip
over this [ __ ] poetry bro that's
great back back the layout backflip that
shit's crazy
what do you think happens like when
they're like all right jamie take a look
and he watches it he's like yeah
it's good
this is like you know this is another
brutal public breakup
yeah i feel for this guy yeah i've told
the story of my buddy going to like a
gucci mane concert and
you know gucci mane is pulling up some
dude's girl on stage and
she's like one hand on him he's like no
babe don't don't check i'm just gonna go
for a little bit he's like no
no no no
jesus this is the this is the most
exaggerated version of that
babe don't go backstage yeah don't go
backstage with a superstar please
please i mean the craziest part if it's
true i think he was on the trip that's
the craziest [ __ ] part
yeah that's ins just
the levels of disrespect i mean i feel
like
you gotta know sending your
your woman your beloved into a a
dark den with drake i mean it's [ __ ]
i just
what do you think is gonna happen that's
like sending [ __ ] lamb to slaughter
homie
yeah but it's like if it's gonna blow if
there's a chance that her career is
gonna blow up oh no it's just
and you guys are engaged for eight years
you've been together
i mean yeah you've got to assume she's
gonna be faithful and that she's gonna
do this for
the both of you but the the whole
premise of his music is just like
being in other women that with no
disregard to her feelings
that's so sick you got a feature babe
it's so exciting what's the song called
i think it's called i'm gonna smash your
fiance
i think the song is called mine now yeah
huh i don't know i don't know
it's just mine now i don't know what
it's about yeah that
um i feel for the guy you know
oh yeah yeah i'd be i'd be doing insane
parkour
yeah if that were me oh yeah i'd be
training to become a strong man
can drake do this yeah
can drake do this flipping a vw bug